(upbeat music)
- [Moshe] Hey, this
is Moshe Kasher.
- [Natasha] And Natasha Laggero.
- [Moshe] We just got
married six months ago.
- [Natash] Which we think
pretty much makes us
qualified to give love
advice to strangers.
- [Moshe] So that's what we did.
We packed up the car, hit the
road, and spread the love.
- [Natasha & Moshe] This
is The Honeymoon Tour.
- Okay, ma'am what's your name?
- Megan.
- Megan, and?
- Zach.
- Megan and Zach,
the whitest possible.
(audience laughing)
Love it.
- [Natasha] And are
you guys married?
- We are, 16 years.
- 16 years?
- We've only been
married for ten years.
- Oh, wow, she only got
it wrong by six years.
- [Moshe] We got a couple of
video e-mails, or requests,
for people that needed love
advice to reach out to us.
- This says "love
advice, drunk advise."
- And it's from someone
who's handle is SteelerGirl.
I think that means like...
- Pittsburgh Steelers
(Natasha laughing)
- Pittsburgh Steelers.
Already a bad sign.
- That's not a good sign.
- Any advise on how to
keep my husband from peeing
on everything when he's
drunk and sleepwalking?
He swears he's just
being a "good boy."
How? Like in what
world would that--
- I'm a good boy... oh like how
a dog is a good boy I guess?
- How 'bout I just
give her the URL to
Alcoholics Anonymous' website?
(Natasha laughing)
I'm literally gonna do
that. Can I do that?
www.AA.org
- Megan, do you have
any problem with Zach?
- Yeah, a pet peeve
of yours about Zach?
- Well, a recent
fight we just had
- Ooh, do tell
(audience cheering)
- "Thank you, good
night," says Zach.
- He told me I had a little
surprise coming in the mail.
- Okay...
- Hitachi Magic Wand.
(audience laughing)
- He bought me
that fuckin' wand.
- Wait, for real?
(audience laughing)
That's... wow...
Oh you want to know what I
don't like about my husband?
I guess I would say he bought me
the best sex toy on the market.
(audience laughing)
- Megan, why were you mad?
- That wasn't something
that I wanted as a gift.
I wasn't happy about it.
- It felt presumptuous, is
that what you're saying?
- It did, it did. I
was a little irritated.
It's huge, it's like a monster,
I mean, I don't want it.
- Oh you got the Moshe Kasher?
(audience laughing)
- Let's see if we
have another one.
- I like this person,
very exotic name, Noful.
Noful: "Me and my girl are
definitely in need of love."
Not advice, just love.
(Natasha laughing)
Noful, that's not your girl.
"She lives in LA, and
I live in 29 Palms.
I haven't seen her since March."
March, April, May,
June, that sucks.
"Make my dream come true."
- Oh, he thinks we're
gonna write him a check.
- Also, what kind of
check you need to write
to get someone from
La Habra to 29 Palms?
It's like a two hour drive.
- He needs 35 dollars.
- Make my dreams come true
of a quarter-tank of gas.
- I was so pissed at him,
I didn't talk to
him for like a week.
- Why?
- [Audience Member] Because
she was too busy getting it on!
(audience laughing)
- That is probably exactly...
Oh we are done here.
No, I am pissed, I'll
talk to you later.
- Wait, Zach, I'm
curious, was that like
you were like, oh
this is something I
know she's gonna like?
Or, this is a sign?
Or this is a message
I want her to receive?
What was your instinct
with that present?
- I thought she might like it.
It's the best sex
toy on the market.
- He researched it.
He said it's like
the best vibrator for
ya know, women after
they have kids.
- Okay, I think I maybe...
I think I might have
found the problem.
(audience laughing)
You might be bad at dirty talk.
- What do you mean,
"make your...
dreams...
Come...
true?"
- Do you need some gas money?
And say "Lovingly, Motasha."
- Lovingly...
Mo-...
tasha.
- Here's what I think.
You need to incorporate
the sex toy together.
Cause I remember one time...
Well I don't want to
say this, it's personal.
- What is it?
Oh yeah, that's fucked up.
- It's too personal, yeah.
- Okay, right, right,
we owe it to them.
- Well, for example if
you're dating someone
who watches a lot of
porn, you could like...
(audience laughing)
- No, you're right,
it's too personal.
- You could watch
the porn with them,
and then incorporate, like turn
that into sex or something.
- Right, Natasha didn't
even know what a BBW was.
(audience laughing)
- But, you know, like, why
don't you not take it as like
oh, this is something I'm
supposed to do on my own,
and this is something
that you guys do together?
- Yeah...
- Okay, so Megan
could be open to that.
Could you do that
tonight, Megan?
(audience cheering)
- Should we wrap it up?
- Okay, let's give it
up for Megan and Zach!
- Give it up for Megan and Zach!
- I dated a guy once
that peed the bed
from being drunk,
and it was not fun.
- I dated a girl once
when we would have sex,
she would start
screaming, and then
all of the sudden, like
she would pee a lot.
Like every time she
would be like "Oh my god,
oh my god, oh my god," and
then she would pee a lot.
- You mean she would
have a... she would come?
- Oh is that what that was?